[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my friend went on to become
the beetle okay welcome back to the
break room everybody uh another episode
of Tommy's uh very scary stories show
um
It's Our Daily Show that keeps you
updated on the nerdy news you need to
know
um Today's Show brought to you by Pluto
TV which offers hundreds of free live
channels and thousands of free on-demand
movies they've been sponsoring the show
all week we appreciate you Pluto TV uh
coming up on today's episode venom
getting a new Direction with a new
director William Jackson William Harper
Jackson almost said William Jackson
Harper that's a very different guy uh
lands in a good place and we gained some
clarity on vision and much more
specifically some Doom some Fantastic
Four some speculation with me to do that
we've got Whitney van laningham
[Music]
get arms legs in a face
uh uh we've got Jay Washington's here I
just I like how Zach was like yeah we
got Jay Washington we're gonna get Tommy
that's the big important part I'm glad
to be back I wanted to Gap it a little
bit so you didn't have to follow a dog
you know what I mean exactly
she doesn't need to get top billing over
you listen he can't even read it
normally the only dog on the break room
Tommy back though I got that dog and let
me put you this way
this crew of people
even though there is still a rotten
apple core of a chat going on during the
show three people I love so much on the
show with me today and in fact I'd like
to introduce you to a new friend of mine
I brought my newest member of the
Bechtel family thumbs down you losers
you fell for it again I can't own
animals not after my dog circus got shut
down
uh right that's another scary scary tale
for a different day
um yeah it's not me mentioned thank you
to everybody in the chat uh it's a
Redemption of day now Jessica Clemens is
not here uh today she's prepping uh I I
heard she is uh it takes her four days
to prep her Halloween costume so um
she's already started that process but
she did this is true she didn't prep our
chat Redemption she did these are all
Truth or Dare uh prompts that will be
spurred every time we hit 100 bucks in
the Super Chat Jessica wrote all of
these yeah I've not seen them I don't
know I'm gonna do a sample just so you
guys see what we got we all have no idea
we're Flying Blind here this is one of
the truths
these fingers were made for loving yeah
all right that's what I'm talking about
a hole this small enough
okay this is Truth uh truth do you love
Jessica Clemons if so how much if not
why not wait are all of them
camera four
most people know I don't have a lot
going out for me okay my life could best
be described as tragic uh with a little
blend of what the hell happened to that
guy he had so much potential the
opportunities I've squandered in my life
are more than any of you trash bags will
ever even be offered I have one reason
to get up in the morning and that's
Jessica Clemens she's my son but she's
also my moon because I want to think
about her in the morning and in the
evening okay she's like a pizza bagel to
me Jessica Clements in the morning
Jessica Clemens in the evening Jessica
Clemens that's up at the time when
Jessica Clemens is your best friend you
can have Jessica Clemens anytime okay
all right that's the uh okay the level
of strangeness you can expect from the
Redemption look I didn't know what to do
I sipped for guests
God knows I sent for Whitney and I've
been sipping for Zach since 2009. uh I
thought that was sipping
um okay let's let's move on to the
headlines of the day yes uh it's
actually a really good day for nerdy
news today
um first off we haven't been talking
about the Venom franchise for a minute
yeah uh but Venom three is in the works
and it has a director Kelly Marcel it's
probably a name you don't recognize
she's never directed anything before she
has been a producer on the previous two
Venom films yeah supposedly he's a close
collaborator with Tom Hardy I'm kind of
speculating it's a little bit of a
hearty power move yeah in there right
Andy Circus directed Let There Be
Carnage he's a known director he's
working for a lot of my franchises this
is like hey I'm Gonna Keep I'm gonna
have my director do this yes yes I like
that I think Hardy is taking control of
the Venom franchise he's like look these
movies have made over a billion dollars
combined this is a billion dollar
franchise say what you want I personally
am a fan I and I'd like to say why are
you caveating it yeah say what you want
because your heart listen I happen to
know if you venomous haters in my life
and I try and tell them I'm like listen
you can say you don't like the movies
yeah it's fine Jay put your hand right
up and then give me a five
okay because that's the type of
positivity we're bringing to this Friday
uh no I I hope Eminem comes back and
makes a song I was gonna say I hope
Eminem is director of Venom four
give me
give me a morbius cameo in this movie
give me one give me two let them swim
somewhere give me seven more minutes we
might have news about this this is too
much about morbius that is way too much
Cameo a single a single hormone is
mentioned is too much it's just too many
literally okay swerving away from this
bum c and to the normal MCU Daniel bro
bro uh it's a German last name uh AKA
Baron Zemo I can pronounce that sorry I
just want to stop you real quick Baron
helmet Zemo okay thank you as I learned
from yesterday yesterday
like helmet Lang yeah fashion designer
yes
but uh he was he did an interview
recently where he's asked it where we're
going to see Zemo next and of course
because he's a smart guy and he doesn't
spoil any Marvel news he he's you know
he said I don't know uh zemo's Not Dead
AKA we're gonna see him in something now
he has not of all the people that have
been announced to be involved in the
Thunderbolts movie we got Elena we got
Red Guardian yeah we got John Walker
right all those characters Sebastian
Stan that's Bucky Barnes the Winter
Soldier um no no Zemo so far he's not in
the poster hasn't been announced to be
involved in that movie but in the comics
of course emo is a huge part often of
the Thunderbolt sometimes the leader
yeah of the Thunder well you know I've
heard an interesting Theory I believe
somewhere on the new rockstars channels
that believes that are that states that
ultimately by the end of thunderbolts
Zemo will be in charge oh there's a
little bit of a Valentina might either
get
or displaced or kidnapped or maybe she's
in cahoots with Zemo I love kahoots I
mean look they there's so many people
involved in all these projects coming up
and the people who are involved have
signed 37 ndas before we started this
show and so they are not going to tell
you anything and why you you good you
need to have a snoring dog
you need a sleep apnea machine you know
what baby I think it's time for you to
go back to work in the big office okay
[Music]
I hate the fact we're always hearing
people are asking these people stars who
are the movies and TV shows when we go
see you next knowing good and damn well
they're not gonna tell you yeah they're
not gonna it's like you're trying to get
a sound bite that you're not gonna get
right I mean granted we have this
conversation going right now which is
what you want but it in general you're
like well more than likely this one
thing but nothing confirmed right yeah
and honestly though though of course
we're gonna reporters are gonna ask
these questions as fans we don't want to
know how great would it be if you don't
know say it again
we need some surprises left in our lives
and I know I say that as an employee of
new rockstars where we come to let's go
and clip to try to spoil everything
possible boom did I surprise you you did
thank you Tommy
um yes and so uh speaking of speaking of
things that are still gonna be surprises
we've got some casting news otherwise
quantumania now this is a movie that is
wrapped right it's coming out in
February we already got a trailer for it
but we just got a casting announcement
that's kind of been hinted at before but
uh um William Jackson Harper confirmed
to be there he is confirmed to be an
Ant-Man in the WASP quantumania now they
have not confirmed who's playing and in
fact they're being purposefully
secretive about it they refuse to say
who he's playing uh Marvel and you know
he's a big time actor in fact we're
going to make him today's fresh face wow
what an honest that's right uh we do
this every every once in a while we do a
fresh face Friday brought to you by
geology skincare uh you know a segment
where we celebrate a new face who's
coming to the MCU uh and this week we're
highlighting Mr Harper
um now you might recognize him certainly
if you're a fan of the wonderful sitcom
the good place if you caught the
Underground Railroad on Amazon or
Midsummer that freaky uh Scandinavian
horror movie
um he's worked a lot in the last five
years I guess he's on that Jack Ryan
series too I haven't watched that but
then season three I believe premieres
soon okay with Krasinski yeah um
Krasinski Johnny craft uh
some people have been speculating that
um William Jackson Harper could have
some connections to the Fantastic Four
which John Krasinski is often associated
with Tommy's uh uh putting some geology
skincare to work
um that that they if you don't know how
to take care of your skin a lot of folks
cry out for me I'm making my skin tight
and right um they offer our friends at
geology offer a whole range of products
to help your skin look its best and they
even help you figure out what you need
you take a little quiz on your website
you can go to the link that's on screen
right now or to send this video's
description take a little quiz you get
the oily skin the dry skin acne wrinkles
whatever and they kind of give you all
the great products that will help you uh
stay fresh-faced like William Jackson
Harper this feels good okay my face
feels fresh we have wait which one did
you use this no I use this this is the
Facebook okay
we crossed over 50. so I'm just gonna
real quick oh okay and real quick let me
wrap up I did geology.com new rockstars
use the promo code rockstar70 to save
yourself 70 off your order 70 off that's
a lot yes that's a really good okay
Tommy we've got a little bit of a
Redemption then we're going to come back
and speculate on who he might be playing
I know I simped for Jess a little bit on
the first truth but I ain't going to
apologize my skin is glowing Lily thank
you so much uh I'm gonna do truth again
actually you know what screw it I'm
gonna do there oh man
I'm just afraid they're gonna make me
well Tommy pulls that out thanks to
Haley Caroline Hot Rod Baker Zach
Braddock also uh pickle brick from New
Zealand in the chat I don't know it's
like tomorrow there okay
look at camera four and tell the
audience how you really feel about Black
Widow
this is a dare this is the truth is it
dare but it's technically a truth it is
a dare well yeah because the internet is
unforgiving listen to me I'm going to
address the film and not the politics
behind the film oh
Black Widow featured the most
unnecessary green and blue screening in
a feature film of my entire I've ever
seen in my entire life they blue
screened a scene where they're sitting
at a gas station picnic table having a
conversation do you know we're in Los
Angeles there are
15 million gas stations that have picnic
tables outside of them they couldn't use
one of those practically we got to go
build like fake elements of that
Scarlett Johansson Alzheimer big fan big
fan Florence Pugh huge fan incredible
David Harbor huge fan Rachel Vice look
at my MySpace from 2004.
you will understand the feelings I have
towards racial Vice uh
the bad guy sucked Drake off was
terrible it's not his fault I like that
actor there's just nothing to him he was
a guy in a suit with a ring that made
made release pheromones you know what I
wear a lot of jewelry no one's attracted
to me you're currently wearing no juice
you have no jewelry on at all am I or is
it invisible super Cree technology
jewelry that's so cool or is it all
hidden is it all piercings you can't see
anyway why introduce pigs that can be
controlled by an iPad if there's no
payoff for that technology there's no
piercing I thought it was this nipple no
it's just hard all the time okay I call
this one by North Star this one the
Renegade okay all right anyway that's
great that's how I feel I feel like that
movie was not my favorite kind of a mess
feel like they deleted a lot out of it I
feel like they did Scarlet wrong then
they then they had a lawsuit they gave
her some more money you're gonna wreck
should have come out in theaters the
soul covered no I'm just kidding okay no
in all seriousness I understand why I
had to come out on streaming because of
Health precautions and I know they held
it for a long time that movie was doomed
before it started it I think that we
will be kinder to it as time progresses
and more of it makes sense and the
character of yulina really takes flight
yeah that is her introduction yeah same
same with red Garden right guardian and
we're going to see okay I want to come
back to William Jackson Harper they're
not saying who he's going to play we've
been speculating around the office oh
you could just be like one of the
citizens of the quantum realm maybe he's
a leader in Cosmopolis or whatever the
name of that place might be but like
maybe they would probably tell us if his
name is gag gorg or whatever and he's
the mayor of Cairo
one of your favorites all he does is gag
good evening
all right
Tommy's gag reflexes yeah the gagging
waiters sketched on the Dana Carvey yeah
you don't know my nickname in college
was the gag head okay all right Jay was
about to make I think a Cogen Point here
oh I'm sorry Jake no no worries no
worries uh I don't think he's anybody in
that City oh I don't think because
you're not just like you said they would
have told you he was somebody in that
City we've seen steals that there are
people we've seen that there's like big
ass technology in buildings and it looks
better than every downtown in every
other Universe they've created he is
somebody super important to the story
going forward yeah and I my speculation
he might be Reed Richards oh yeah I like
it because remember Kang is a descendant
of Reed so a black dude and a black dude
you know this way we don't want nobody
else say when it mixing raises I want to
see a vanilla little chocolate swirl
baby like no you get a record are you
getting an impression of me
I don't want to see no more why did I
keep making them not right
I want my baby with rosy red cheeks okay
you got to make sure my baby
medically overweight yeah
that's impotent he ain't got no spurt
and a butt for days
you could have him be read I love that
because again what a problem with an
actor this prominent Marvel is not
picking up prominent actors for one-offs
like I mean like there are good actors
there are b-list actors there are some
that are like b-plus but then there are
A-list actors and William Jackson Harper
he's hitting that level of A-list so
he's not gonna be around just for one
movie yeah because this is a big setup
he's a younger guy that they would love
to like invest in for the next 10 years
like you're John Jonathan Majors like
your Catherine Newtons right who are
like soon to be rising up or like like
Chris Hemsworth was when he first became
Thor right like they want people going
on their way up that maybe are they're
going to invest in for a bunch of movies
I love that because also right we saw
that shot in the trailer where we see um
Bill Murray right we see he's kind of
one of the only like human faced people
we see in the quantum realm you would
think if like William Jackson Harper was
was his buddy or co-worker or something
like that you know he would be included
in the shop there's a reason they
haven't shown him in any of the footage
yet right yeah love it
um anybody any other thoughts on who
could be playing yeah I I had one and
then I went on an insane rant and I said
I lost it I had one at the tip of my
tongue oh well you were joking obviously
like he couldn't voice one of uh yeah
well that I I mean I meant it as a joke
my concern is like what if they just do
them a little dirty and like Paul Rudd
takes some weird Quantum realm
hallucinogenic by accident and the Ants
start talking to him and it's like
cheese voice
and Snoop Dogg I don't care oh that's a
good one
yeah it's not it's not like William word
projection has like a voice because
people are like I could pick that voice
anywhere so I'm hoping I think some
people were saying maybe Nathaniel
Richards he could be a younger read then
maybe we get an older Reed Richards
which I think a lot of people are kind
of hoping for maybe the Fantastic Four
has been doing their own thing well and
we're obviously going to come back to
Fantastic Four later in the show and
like maybe how this could tie into that
there's a lot of like time questions
about Fantastic Four when that movie is
going to be set and we know that the
quantum realm does stuff with time right
right that's obviously that was the
mechanism for time travel and end game
so okay we're gonna come back to that
but we've got some black panther we're
kind of forever news they they're
releasing some clips now these are like
full seen Clips or not quite full scenes
but like consecutive it's not spliced
together like a trailer so we're not
going to show them in case you want to
be at this point as unawares heading
into the movie unspoiled get all the
these are some fun action sequences
um one of the clips is kind of from the
flooding that we have seen pieces of uh
in previous trailers but this is a more
extended one it features zimbaku kind of
beating the hell out of a pillow con uh
Warrior
um some other kind of cool stuff uh
shuri in a fighter plane kind of deal
yeah um and then the other clip is of
nameor which now I'm realizing the way
um Tina aguerto says is more of a Namor
it's not more no more
maybe maybe it's always been that and we
just all of a sudden be like yeah his
name more because that's what it's
spelled like just name more okay we joke
about that all the time wherever it's
something you've been reading in comics
for years and spelling you know
pronouncing in your brain and I've never
heard it said out loud I get called out
so much for the weird ways that I
pronounce things and I'm like I'm sorry
I learned how to read wrong
okay
um well we're gonna we're gonna mention
some Fantastic Four villains and and
brutally mispronounce them in hilarious
ways
[Music]
um but uh yeah we're excited Jay has
seen the movie he was at the premiere
we've seen some fun pictures of him with
uh
shout out uh Xavier Woods and Big E man
a bunch of other people
uh I will not spoil this movie at all I
because again I'm under embargo just as
much as everybody else I did say like
look this gives you all the all the
things you needed to hit yeah what
everybody wants it to hit it does you
know there are always going to be people
that have their feelings like they
should have t'challa back there's people
gonna have that no matter what but again
this is about moving the story of black
panther forward and no I'm not saying
that just to get rid of t'challa I'm not
saying it any means so don't don't at me
at your mama
um Mom are you watching I think she is
she said she was good with me but yeah
it gives you all of the emotional points
the action points the story points
everything you want this movie to hit it
does
uh and then he put a name pronounced
that name is pronounced Noma Garcia para
okay okay
he's a leader of a different tribe of
people um somebody said it's time for
truth or dare in the uh oh yeah we have
it uh
Jeremy Leah I'm a thug
again these are all written by Jessica
Clemens
that's right realize a mad Titan and the
resonant super villain all right
is done
tell us
hey I gotta read this out loud
keep it tight clinch your butt for the
next three minutes oh my God yeah three
minutes can we get a clock that is a
long time yeah
can you at least pulsate a little bit
does it have to be fully clinched I'm
about to start now okay Jessica again
you throw written by normal host Jessica
Clements is not here today uh I think
mine's gonna be a lot easier mine's the
truth what's the worst thing you've ever
done I think I've mentioned this on the
show before the thing I regret the most
when I was a 19 year old [ __ ] in
college in the State of Florida which is
a pretty low bar to clear me and some
buddies uh ordered pizza and then when
the Domino's delivery driver showed up
we stole the sign off his car oh and now
in hindsight having had a lot of bad
jobs in my life I'm like that guy is
probably working yeah seven dollars an
hour and he probably had to pay for it
uh yeah and he probably had to pay for
it or he got fired or something like
that so you sir whoever you are out
there Gainesville Florida uh Domino's
delivery driver from uh 2003 uh
apologize to you oh wow that's insane
exactly
do you mind if I take this headline
because I have some please
Jeff Schneider from the hot mic podcast
is reporting that Marvel is currently
working on a show featuring Vision that
is called working title Vision Quest I
have a question
for all you Schneider heads out there
there's in the Schneider verse what did
this guy do to get these Scoops I mean
like a scoop a week John and I were
talking and John this is more my shade
than just a scuba week is not journalism
you know like you do a scoop you get you
know you got something big for the New
York Times that's like a once three
times a year thing you're stupid this
guy's scooping everybody he's like that
what do you know he's like the Adrian
wojanowski or Sean
um well here's here's one thing and and
for a background this guy's previously
broken some stories like he said there
was going to be no fantastic forecasting
announcement at d23 he was right he had
is that something poor Jay is uh Jay's
never going to be the same
um
is tight
which for some background there was a
Comics Arc in the 80s West Coast
Avengers called Vision Quest revision is
kidnapped and has his memory wiped a lot
of that story was kind of already been
used in in one division incorporated
into the white Vision kind of origin
story
um uh part of you know their whole kid's
not being real thing
um do we think this is legit do we think
there is a white Vision I mean listen as
much as I I tossed okay
tossed a little bit of uh
on on on Jeff Schneider he does have a
tendency to be right I'm just wondering
I mean is this one guy getting all these
leaks or is he just brilliantly able to
predict things is he one of those people
like you know like the TV shows where
they have the cop that's the psychic cop
but they're really just very observant
and like they're like oh that wall has
this type of paint that was over here he
really reads the tea leaves well well I
I gotta say maybe he has one
[Laughter]
again if you follow professional sports
there's often a lot of leaks about like
free agency signings and stuff like that
and it's often coming from like the
general managers of teams like the
highest Ed people all right um well so I
actually because of Schneider I talked
to my uncle my uncle is a reporter for
the Buffalo News and I was asking him
like how do you get your Scoops and he's
like well
uh How I Learned is one time I was
trying to do an expose on uh on pizza
deliveries so I posed as a Domino's
pizza delivery driver in Florida and I
was delivering pizzas to these college
students and they actually stole my
Domino sign on and
my boss held me at gunpoint for 48 hours
oh no it actually took my pinky fingers
uh and back then there wasn't the
internet so I couldn't write anymore and
it killed my journalism career wait uh
my wife left me and I uh I found comfort
in the uh glassy arms of a syringe okay
all right uh well uh what a what a wild
coincidence that that that matches my
previous story
um okay we want to move on to uh our
main topic here today Fantastic Four
okay
um part of another Jeff Schneider uh
kind of breaking news thing we gotta
come out for a thing for that yeah
Snyder a Schneider bomb a Schneider bomb
is that good Schneider Schneider verse
Schneider curse no don't say Schneider
verse because
Too Close we're gonna take you later
yeah uh Pito also not the right now uh
we'll figure it out throw it in the chat
if you know what we should call when
Jeff Schneider uh drops some news um so
we got we did get some Fantastic Four
movie updates uh the Fantastic Four
writers we've known those previously
Jeff Kaplan and Ian Springer uh they've
been working on the script we know Matt
shackman is on board to direct uh but in
more interesting news Jeff Schneider the
aforementioned uh Schneider Bomb Dropper
uh he's reporting that Dr Doom will not
be the villain of the upcoming Fantastic
Four film okay uh of course every time
we've seen the Fantastic Four in movies
previously yeah I think I'll respect to
Julian McMahon and Tony kebbel but I
think we've we've seen the Dooms on
screen I I wouldn't mind if they slow
play doctor I mean as a you know kind of
like
person who's not overtly evil yet or at
least is not presenting their evidence
you know obviously Thanos has been our
big bad for a while he's gone we know
Kang is currently going to be the big
bad for quite a while maybe they're
saving Doom for first and that's what I
think I think that's what it is I think
we're going to get introduced to him in
another movie in these two phases but I
think he becomes the next big bad
because when you have Thanos and then
you have Kang you have Quantum and
Cosmic elements of bad guys then
actually be like okay what is a Galactus
what is it this give me something
different and doom has taken out the
entire Marvel Universe and remember
Kevin feige keeps saying these phases
are all about technology meeting magic
and he is the one person yes who knows
it best yes that's a really good part I
mean there might be a rogue Theory
coming out tomorrow that really sums
this all up in a really eloquent package
with minimal cursing uh of course we're
not going to minimal cursing I doubt it
uh we're not going to uh project who is
scene he's the only one here that's seen
what kind of forever of course there's
been this long-sending rumor because of
uh Doom's kind of connections to wakanda
and black panther and in in in in Namor
uh in the comics that he might show up
and wakanda forever we're not going to
talk about that it lives as a rumor
until the movie comes out and we can go
watch it uh
yeah oh we're actually getting I'm
picking I picked all that up oh okay you
speak mug I don't know you speak mine I
speak mug
I uh I think that first of all
this is wonderful news to me the Doom is
not going to be the main villain I'm
Fantastic Four there are other I mean we
could have Galactus uh showing up we
could have uh moment personal favorite
of mine shout out to Roger corman's
Fantastic Four uh obviously Kang could
could be uh waiting in the wings maybe
William Harper Jackson's character in
quantumania is going to be set up as the
villain for a Fantastic Four you know
perhaps it's someone that's working
closely uh with uh with with Hank Pym or
maybe it's like hate pims like uh what's
the word Protege or hand cream is a
mentor figure and then something happens
and when he becomes a villain you know
lots of villain origin stories begin
with friendship right well and and like
he could even you can even I I like that
thought like he can start as like a not
villainous character and they give a new
origin to a Comics villain right for a
long time right they're like what
happened to him he's doomed
here's the thing too maybe he could be
just somebody who tests the Fantastic
Four he like you say he could be just
the polar opposite of Reed uh Hank pen
Protege or they just both went to MIT
together and then you know if he's
appeared in Quantum Mania then that's
like oh there's this story about this
guy who knows this other guy this other
guy's Reed Richards things like that but
I agree with keeping Doom away because
if you bring him in it's like oh they
got to get rid of them already yeah they
got to get rid of them I'd rather see a
slow burn leading up yes I like my Doom
to be slow
like I like my women
okay slow secretive not very interesting
with a mask
murderous Army of robots
uh yeah well I like that too because
like oh how great would it be if we get
Doom in a not Fantastic Four property
and then over the course of several
movies we build it's it's like we're
wrestling fans here right you don't you
don't set up your two big guys against
each other early that you need a
multi-year
building to them coming together
right exactly well we're putting more
wrestling into the break room we're
really trying that somebody's been in
the business 20 years I appreciate it
and that's why you know when you're on
we try and show off the next time you're
doing a a live show okay yeah we'll do
an official new rockstars meeting yeah
yes yes that will definitely let it be
nice please do okay uh well we we kind
of previously mentioned and we've kind
of hinted at some options here and I
love Jay's thought that this could be or
somebody said Kang right Tommy maybe
said it but Tommy mentioned molecule man
somebody else said Galactus who else do
we think analyst analyst that's not how
it's pronounced
sorry I mean I'm sorry man but I've been
reading it in the comics as analyst my
whole life and I'm not changing now I
can't change now no room too late back
out of this one no it stands or but
uh I'm gonna defeat the whole world
I've Got the Whole World
Wrestling reference
um yeah and Jay you were mentioning an
interesting option earlier so there's a
bunch of different Fantastic Four
villains A Fantastic Four villain a lot
of people keep forgetting about is in a
movie already
no more Neymar they actually fight him
yeah so you could be keeping they more
like again who knows if we're getting
rid of Neymar after one movie probably
not if you're introducing him we just
talked about it you want people to be
around for a while we're building up to
the biggest thing in Marvel history
being Secret Wars so you want to get
people for when this builds up you're
building up this anticipation so the
Fantastic Four versus Neymar can work
you don't have to kill them off it's
just a battle with the two of them you
know we got to deal with the Fantastic
Four in this world all things start
playing themselves out Kang shows up
maybe he could be like a post-credit
scene villain and everything going
forward yeah yeah I love that yeah a
long history in the comics with The
Fantastic Four
um love that we were saying Kang
variants could even be we don't know at
this point we we've we've met one king
variat and then we've seen in the
trailer for Ant-Man another king variant
but like who knows how many we'll see
and like to the point of like they could
be potentially played by even different
actors they can look very different they
could be from all kinds of different
times and places and all this kind of
stuff give us a lady
[Music]
[Applause]
you make me feel like you mean
[Applause]
uh I love that oh
okay great it's like Carl Carl Weathers
and Arnie and uh Predator right there
yeah
I get it uh yeah and so one of the
long talked about again Fantastic Four
is just in the scripting stage we
haven't gotten any casting news things
like that but like long rumored that
this could be set in a time that is not
the modern MCU I would love right
Fantastic Four is like one of the oldest
Marvel properties this could be at least
begin in the 60s also known to do some
time traveling of their own so like you
know and then they maybe travel to the
view uh to the Future present uh
something like that you know it could be
a kind of a different genre feel to it
than most of the other markets a friend
of ours uh comedian and writer named Dan
Mcneil uh wrote a brilliant treatment
for a Madman style Fantastic Four story
for a comic book run it's so good I
don't know if it'll ever get made I hope
it does I mean he's broke because it was
he said it in the 60s and it was like
all of the tropes of how awful people
were then but with Fantastic Four Powers
it was I just want them to call it days
of future past two yeah
but also if you do the 60s which I'm
hoping they do because again they're or
just do the First Act of the movie in
the 60s just the First Act but also the
one beautiful thing you'll get is king
t'chaka oh
oh you can get King to chocolate and we
know like it'll be a Howard Stark
floating around yes
could just come ripping up all these
people we think about you know in the in
the more present and forward MCU could
just be there in that First Act that's
it did we find out that Peggy Carter
went through an LSD phase in the 60s
streets and when Steve went in the ice
her and the Howling Commandos went out
and then they went in yeah
howling
um yeah I love that I also think there's
a decent chance when we meet the
Fantastic Four obviously that's going to
be
Marvel's going to really invest in that
they're going to want that to be a huge
franchise right A lot of times our kind
of first movie villain is not the big
right like vulture in Spider-Man
homecoming right it's not every
anybody's idea of the biggest Spiderman
villain right right but it was perfect
because we mostly want to spend most of
the movie the Spider-Man right not
establishing some whenever Doom does
show up he's gonna need a lot of air
time right we're going to want to do
that he showed up in the chat okay oh
there he is Doctor Dooms
yeah I I would have expected uh lavarian
dollars yeah in U.S currency what's the
exchange rate yeah
American dollars is 10.5 billion oh wow
they're dealing with some coins
um yeah very uh anyways there's there's
a lot to be discussed Jeff Schneider
will probably I was gonna say Doom dimes
but yeah it's better nope yours is
better you're my queen
I'm a lady I'm a lady we give to you my
lady
uh I want to say
it's Friday Act of Mercy thank you for
everyone for watching uh watching the
show and for all the super chats thank
you to the chat you know we have our
differences but at the end of the day
we're all best friends you better have
liked and subscribed this or I swear to
God I'm gonna take something that you
care about oh my God okay well uh a
kidney a trinket from your little trash
bin maybe I'll come to your house
throw up cinnamon barfs all over it from
yesterday I don't know maybe I take a
plastic bag out of my car full of old
baseball cards I whip it at your mom's
face just [ __ ] subscribe okay hey hey
I'm not saying I'm definitely gonna
I'm just saying like And subscribe at
five four I'm sorry okay well real quick
Tommy's messages but uh MLS beats has a
is a great Super Chat when do you think
we're are we gonna see the Fantastic
Four before they're moving I think we're
just gonna get the imagery Baxter
building I think we're gonna get a
baxter yeah we're not getting them
because I think that's another surprise
I really I would love if we never got
anything about the Fantastic Four not a
trick not even in the movie you know
just nothing nothing
and then they went to space Oh my God
could you imagine if a Marvel movie was
a retrospective on the topic of the
movie they're like and then at the very
end they're like they caught they crash
in through space that would be a great
special presentation actually if they
did that on one of the X-Men or like or
like a Nightcrawler they're like Kurt
Wagner hasn't been seen in years and I
think like one of the big riddles of the
next two or three phases for Marvel is
how they're going to incorporate these
formerly Fox properties right like how
do you justify the X-Men and the
Fantastic Four why why didn't they help
out with all this other stuff right
where have they been I think it always
has to be either I mean
or they're new or they have to give them
new orders yeah like they're just
they're emerging
um five four three two one I don't want
to think butcher box for sponsoring the
show today
the candy train is coming it's Halloween
weekend or as Dennis call it
but rather than sweets this weekend I'm
turning into Meats thanks to butchers
thank you butcher bugs with butcher box
I get peace of mind when it comes to
buying meat butcher box takes all the
guesswork out of finding high quality
Meat and seafood you can trust and as a
man who's had a lot of trust issues with
his Seafood that is comforting 100
grass-fed beef free range organic
chicken pork raised great free you see
pork in a crate that ain't butcher box
that's some competitor
swap slot box you know what and by the
way they're overpriced okay wild caught
Seafood I'm talking Seafood that
disobeys its parents and then straight
in Neptune's neck Nemo Nemo
well guess what he's on my plate yum yum
okay Pixar out of my teeth all right
it's always you're mainly raised no
antibiotics no added hormones get to
guess what you want delivered right to
your doorstep or if you're like me uh
your butler grabs it through the gate
from some peasant mailman free shipping
for the continental U.S no surprise fees
choose from a variety idea of box plan
options from curated to customized you
want a box full of pork chops they'll do
it for you you want a box full of salmon
because you're a grizzly bear rare going
up to your door butcher box is my new
teammate and my never-ending quest to
save better and save money eat better
and save money they're like Josh Allen
I'm like Gabe Davis toe drag on the end
zone line that's six for the Buffalo
Bills over the Packers the main course
for Thanksgiving dinner can sometimes be
a main source of stress not anymore tell
Tony to put his toe furkey in his
freezer because butcher box is offering
our listeners free turkey with their
first order sign up today at
butcherbox.com break room to get one 10
to 14 pound turkey free in your first
box that's butcherbox.com break room use
the code to help us guys use the code
break room to claim this deal it makes
us look good butcher box is happy with
us Zach and I need our meat treats
Whitney loves the bacon I want a box of
salmon now
roast delivered in a box once a month 40
pounds good job he just uses it for
working out and once again all week and
for the last couple weeks we cannot
thank Pluto TV enough for sponsoring the
break room and our house of dragon
finale Pluto tv offers hundreds of free
live channels and thousands of free
on-demand movies you don't gotta leave
your house no who wants to do that also
I just want to shout out uh new
rockstars will be releasing and all ads
Tommy podcast some point soon uh where
it's just uh they're not even the
sponsoring they're paying us it's just
entertaining because let's put it this
way I Am for sale in every way you can
think of
oh no it was late last night I was up
real late I didn't have a female date I
was home alone eating cookies and cake
when I realized I was watching deep
fakes I watched deep fakes that's not at
half the way I watched the face there's
no way Scarlett Johansson did a gang
bang I watched these things
no way that's my Halloween
that's uh I've heard of Boris Karloff
that's who Boris
giving you the black widow you really
want all right guys deep fakes uh no
good don't support that that technology
is terrifying toxic if you do all I did
the only the only banging I watched was
Tom Brady's head against the ground as
he was slaughtered on Thursday Night
Football wow
yet but that's what happens when you
turn your back on your family
mandatory fun I was in my Mansion this
morning uh I went outside to walk my
Shetland ponies with a man and a
scarecrow mask handed me a bowl of candy
and I thought that was generous
he told me not to worry everything was
legit with the candy so I said that's
great I have three people I really adore
coming on the show there's four pieces
of candy in here there's no way it's
laced with anything let's do some
trick-or-treating
this is pretty cool scarecrow scarecrow
man wow gave me this bucket of candy in
the McDonald's adult book I love candy I
just hooked my jeans on my chair and
almost dropped Trout
the entire uh audience okay
these are not laces they're perfect
natural and this is a so added this is a
share Size Snickers I gotta say the
Scarecrow was feeling generous now
there's something there's like a piece
of paper in here oh no I'm sure it's
just normal you can go ahead and eat it
should I well should I read the piece of
paper uh well once you've touched it
it's already in your system
okay now the paper is uh it's taped on
it's taped on the precarious
okay uh I guess I owe it to the
Scarecrow to at least read the uh the
message okay oh whoa uh this is on topic
I guess spoiler Henry Cavill will be
playing Perry white while Timothy
chalamet will be playing Superman oh no
so these are faced with bad things these
are trick candies you guys
the street scarecrow is a demon because
this one is oh wow true serum admit one
geek movie you don't like uh y'all have
to come to me laugh I'm gonna go on the
rant about this one okay
oh no what's yours what's yours oh no
mine's gonna be sad mine's F Mary kill
Harley Quinn Eddie Munson and Keanu
Reeves one of them already died I'm not
making him go through that again uh ah
jeez okay so then I'm down here nasty
bastard that's a nasty nasty question
okay so I'm gonna F Harley Quinn
obviously she looks so fun and then uh
I'm gonna definitely marry Eddie Munson
because he deserves a second shot at
life I'm only killing Keanu Reeves
because he hasn't Matthew Perry fan yeah
he's old enough to die and Eddie Munson
was a team
the world's greatest treasure I agree I
agree but I also agree with Whitney now
this is crazy mine just says clown show
when you are both Macho Man introducing
himself to Al Pacino oh my God okay well
I have to do it it's in my laced candy
bar
Al Pacino
my name is Randy Macho Buffalo
Macho Man and I think you're a fabulous
actor hey there Randy uh
I
I'm Al Pacino oh she's got a great ass
I'm talking about Miss Elizabeth these
inches are everywhere in my pants all
right oh El Pacino why are you talking
about my wife that way lowered the cage
I'm gonna fight you oh you don't gotta
do that ah I think I am I it was a
Scarface your cockroach
I'm Scarface they're building a little
bit I can't stop it
I can't stop Macho Man Al Pacino over
here
all right oh yeah uh we've got some good
candy
um
that was great um oh sorry yeah yeah
okay so true serum
huh admit one geek movie you don't like
Zack Snyder's over indulgence of him
damn self in a snyderverse movie that
was four unnecessary freaking hours long
he could have been like 30 something
minutes less and it would have been a
perfect movie but no this dick headed to
be like I need more slow motion to make
it seem like the black dude does a lot
except be a creep cause nobody really
wants to talk about the fact that cyborg
stalked a woman at the ATM so her life
was in jail because it was like I'm
gonna help her you are a criminal okay
you are a crook and your daddy don't
love you either I wonder I need to make
sure we see Icelandic women singing with
Jason Momoa takes his shirt off of doing
the cold ass water for what okay there
we go I'm done
that's a wonderful note to wrap on uh we
hope
what's that oh we we owed some more
redemptions now I could I'll do a dare
if anybody else is feelings yeah what
you want to DARE truth
um okay this is again these were all all
of these are truth or dares written by
Jessica Clemens oh my God this is great
um they're pretty strange mine is
literally recite the Pledge of
Allegiance while looking into the eyes
of the person to your left yeah Tommy
Bechtel Pledge of Allegiance let's see I
haven't I probably haven't said this
since sixth grade so um uh I pledge
allegiance to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation under God
indivisible with Justice and liberty
liberty and justice okay I flipped it
okay back when I was a little kid I used
to uh have to do the Christian flag
Solutions
and that brings me to my Dare for the
next 10 minutes I have to interrupt
people with personal anecdotes great
well I'm gonna do my truth have you ever
pooped your pants as an adult if so why
the answer is yes but there's a more
recent
and that's last night I was uh driving
home from work uh late one night and I
gave myself an awful fright I had
drinking too much of my Coke Zero the
toilet bowl was gonna be my hero I
started this friend I started to Sprint
upstairs I started to Sprint and I had
the braised up hairs on my neck then I
pissed my jeans I didn't make it it was
a grizzly scene I pissed a softball size
stain in my jeans I'm 38 years old and I
have no wife and children
happy Halloween everyone the costume I'm
going as is clown and I wear it every
day oh my God mine is true
what's the meanest thing you've ever
said to your mom rest in peace Mama I
love you but I once told my mom I can
hear you having sex with your man and
the [ __ ] sounds horrible you sound like
a diet dolphin
oh my God
uh that's incredible oh Jessica Clemens
in the chat
uh when I was a about 10 I you I learned
the word plebeian in social studies
class and I thought my mom would never
know what it meant and so I started
calling my mom a plebeian all the time I
thought it was cool and that she
wouldn't know I got so grounded so fast
uh shout out to all the moms uh shout
out to the moms of the chat watching
channel tell the moms of the folks on
this show living and dead
um uh shout out to all the uncomfortable
experiences we've had with our moms
um that's wonderful and and thanks to
the folks Super Chat MLS beads pushing
us to do some more dares Jessica
Clements in confused but love this Al
Pacino Savage we all did Rupert Jamison
Air Force Reserve Sergeant Walker Jacob
Beach also um Justin gilsby happy
birthday Justin Gilson happy birthday
Justin happy birthday
uh lots of uh again Dr Doom Corey
candrelli in the chat thank you
everybody uh thank you everybody that's
been with us all week this was a while
last week yeah on the break room and
we're gonna have a lot of fun we got two
trailers this week we probably won't get
two trailers next week but we will get
um some more black panther wakanda
forever yeah I'm gonna go see it two
weeks okay not quite who knows what a
leak this week no no we'll avoid leaks
uh but uh we look forward to seeing you
next week
um I'm about to make another softball
[Laughter]
uh thank you uh thank you everybody
thank you to Pluto TV uh offering
hundreds of free live channels and
thousands of free on-demand movies
um bless you uh check out new rockstars
uh like And subscribe follow us on
socials follow Jay Jay what's your
social you can buy me on Twitter
Instagram and Tick Tock please follow me
at mrjwashington m-r-j-a-y you should
not as well Washington I promise you you
will not be disappointed on Instagram
nor on Twitter or Tick Tock if they
don't be in Black
also find uh he does live shows of the
stand up and occasionally the wrestling
version yes I'll be all over everywhere
if you're in the Los Angeles area we're
working on some things right now for the
beginning of 2023 I'll be on the road
doing a lot of stand up uh no more
wrestling shows as of right now for the
rest of the year but after this I got
two shows tonight I'm shows tomorrow
next day next day it's just been blessed
everybody and check out America jig
along show time
and uh Whitney do you want to pledge
yourself oh yeah hi I'm Whitney you know
at Whitney puppy because I like puppies
and my name is Whitney go follow me
that's it and tell me you're not allowed
on social media
you can follow me at my secret social
network
my profile name is Daddy Daddy sugar
cane and all I talk about is Sweet
Treats oh [ __ ] interrupting again with a
personal anecdote that I just realized
it's actually relevant you should follow
Pugsley my dog the pug that you saw in
the beginning he's at Pugsley
p-u-g-s-l-e-y underscore underscore
Adams add AMS spelled like The Addams
Family go follow him he's really cute uh
all of that and have yourself a
wonderful weekend have a great Halloween
everybody be safe don't do anything keep
it give me Gucci later skaters
[Music]
thank you
[Music]